well it wasn't an overnight success in
that way I mean I think when it first
came out
generally the reviews at another comedy
by Harold Ramos it's kind of cute you
know two to two-and-a-half star kind of
reviews but there were other places
where people seem to dig it right away
I was getting letters from Germany and
from England a lot of fans in England
who just thought it was an extraordinary
extraordinary movie and and my feeling
was I felt justified as yeah that's what
it was supposed to be and it was just
very slowly that people realized that
everybody was sort of saying oh you seen
Groundhog Day it was really good and
there was just sort of a buzz started
developing and then little things
started happening like there was a big
Buddhist convention in San Francisco and
somebody delivered a paper about
Groundhog Day and Buddhism and and
people realized that that people were
psychologists were showing it to their
patients prescribing it and all kinds of
different religious disciplines were
embracing it and giving sermons and
lectures and writing important papers
based on the philosophy of Groundhog Day
and Harold Ramis was also getting
letters and notes and the two of us
would compare things like wow this is
really interesting and then at some
point I guess Roger Ebert wrote not a
retraction but a new review that sort of
said I think we should revisit this
movie I think this is a little better
than I thought
and I know at the end of the year that
it came out in 93 William Goldman the
screenwriter was reflecting on movies of
the past year and he was the one who
wrote I think Groundhog Day is the one
that will be of all of the movies that
came out this year it's the one that
will be remembered in ten years and
perhaps that gave it some street cred or
got some people thinking but I don't
know I think people just liked it and a
little bit at a time
it started to develop this not exactly a
following but an awful lot of people who
identified with it
I have thought a lot about that but
everybody seems to have their own reason
and that's what makes it so remarkable
everybody seems to bring their own way
of thinking in their own discipline to
bear on the ideas within it and would
Express this is absolutely describing
the essence of Judaism this is the
essence of Nietzsche's philosophy this
is the essence of homeopathy I mean I've
seen all of this we understand how
people grow and develop in a linear time
fashion how you have an adolescence at a
certain age and you start to develop
adulthood and you start to mature but I
think the movie shows that it is the
repetition of days itself which pushes
us forward in our own maturation as we
start to encounter the same things over
and over again and so there's an element
of truth to the fact that we are
repeating the same day over and over
again but I think the biggest thing that
that affects people is the fact that
phil is presented with the exact same
day and the very first time he's
presented with it it's probably the
worst day of his life and by the end of
the movie we see that the it's the exact
same day but somehow this is probably
the best day of his life it's the day he
fell in love and and she fell in love
with him and and everybody loves him and
he was living a fulfilling life pursuing
culture and things that he loved and
appreciating the day and doing good
works and and contributing to society
and it makes it very clear that we are
in control of our day we can control our
futures there's something very
empowering about it and Groundhog Day
it's almost an experiment that says see
here's a guy who is having a terrible
day and he's kind of a horrible person
and just through the act of repetition
and paying attention and remembering he
is forced to change who he is
and by changing who he is he changes the
life that he experiences the world
around him that I think is is the main
thing that gets people very excited
about the movie